[Music]
thank you everyone and thank you geo for
that warm introduction
as you can see geo has come into the
forefront as one of the leads of this
local community here and you can see
he's developed a very good managerial
skill for every compliment you give
somebody take him down a notch as well
okay so what this talk is we'll see
where this talk goes I'm a little bit
worried about if it's gonna shape up in
the end but hopefully we'll show you
something interesting I first came to
this event the first year was run when
it was on the floating barge boat and I
gave a talk about adding the print
statement back to Python 3 and it was
kind of a joke talk and if something I
threw together at the last minute and I
thought well this year I want to give a
talk about something useful and so I
spent all my time trying to do something
useful and ran out of time to actually
put it together into a talk and actually
collecting the data for this talk turned
out to be very difficult but you'll see
the general idea here but in order to
motivate this what I wanted to do is I
wanted to take something I've worked on
a long time ago that when I showed to
people they looked and they said that's
really weird like what on earth is that
and they thought it was kind of fun and
then show how some of these techniques
aren't just for fun they're actually
useful so let me show you something just
kind of cool and we'll do it with just
so I'm just gonna start a Python
interpreter and you're gonna see that
I'm starting a Python interpreter that I
have here myself I just built this
myself earlier this is like the latest
version of Python it's three seven B
four so it's what will be released in
probably another a couple months maybe
even shorten that and you can see I have
a simple example and I can do things
like add numbers and in this path Python
interpreter I added a little thing
called set our watch and set our watch F
and if we look at the help text for this
the help text is really unhelpful
because if it even pops up something
this gets really slow but oh and
sometimes it seg faults you know this is
what this was done a rush but I'll show
you from sis import set or watch F and
it's a function that takes
a couple of arguments and I won't even
tell you what those arguments are but I
can do something kind of interesting and
you don't know what this does yet but
we'll talk about this in a second and
maybe some of you have even seen this
before okay so we'll go back as a normal
Python interpreter and has like the
number one and it has you know x equals
one and what's what's one plus one for
it's eight right and if we say x equals
two and we say what's X what's two times
two it's 64 right so we can do some kind
of weird things by patching the
interpreter and we can look at this and
we can say what on earth is going on you
fundamentally changed the way python
works you've turned the number one into
the number two the number two into the
number four and when you add two plus
two you'd think that's four but it's
actually eight and you can do all sorts
of really crazy things and the behavior
you know if we we change that little our
watch function to do some random stuff
we could really cause someone to have a
really bad day but the question is how
is this actually useful and so I wanted
to revisit this idea and another idea
that I talked about at PI day to Berlin
two years ago called the quarks problem
I'm going to show you a problem that
almost all of you have run into in your
real lives how many here use pandas how
many here used matplotlib so in pandas
we have like the series object right and
the series object has an apply function
right let's look at the help text of
that apply function can somebody tell me
all the arguments that the apply
function takes no it's got this star
star quarks and if we read through this
help text we don't actually know what
can be passed in there we know some of
this stuff can be passed down but we
can't really tell like what are all the
possible arguments many of you use
pandas and if you look at the help text
of Pi plot plot you have the same
problem star arts star star quarks but
in this case they've at least tried to
be kind of helpful so if you scroll to
the bottom of it it'll say the quarks
are these properties and if you look at
the documentation online they actually
hedge it a little bit and they say well
let's see it's right here
they say here are a list of available
properties but this isn't even the
exhaustive list
so we don't really know all the
arguments you can pass in but here's
some of them that we think you kind of
can that have worked and past that I'm
sure if you're copying the code from
online somewhere maybe somebody would
have done that and if it caused an error
well there's Stack Overflow right in
some cases it's even worse like if you
look at a lot of these functions you
know this takes a star star quarks what
on earth like are the code those
parameters be there's almost no
documentation here and let's talk about
why this happens could anyone anyone
have an idea why this pattern might
exist and why this pattern might be very
common to these two libraries pandas and
matplotlib and many other similar
libraries that we use in data science
exactly so the problem is if we think
about these two libraries one of the
things that typifies these two libraries
is that there is a very complex
hopefully consistent engineering core
and then lots of layers of conveniences
matplotlib is a prime example nobody
here wants to manage the matplotlib draw
tree it's just it's just too
inconvenient it's too clumsy so instead
we use PI plot and PI plot takes three
arguments you know when you pass the
color you just pass like a single letter
like G or R and it figures out what the
actual color is from that you know if
you do a hist it does a lot of work in
the background and so what you see for a
library like matplotlib is a core that
is very consistent and very mechanical
and all the mechanics are worked out
very nicely and then this this layer
that is incredibly critical to actual
users of convenience functions that just
call all that stuff now if you think
about it if you are the author of a
library like that and you have some core
function and that core function took a
bunch of arguments and then you had some
convenience function on top you don't
want to hard code these arguments why
not because somewhere inside you're
going to be doing something like this
and every time this core changes you'll
have to change the convenience layer and
the problem is the convenience layer
probably changes much more often it's
much more reactive to user requests or
user desires it's much more reactive to
different ways that people use this
library so you want to find some way to
avoid adding in this dependency well the
problem is when you do this
you completely remove the dependency now
this convenience method takes any
arguments back and just forwards it
along and so you're free to change this
core function as much as you want as
long as the user is correctly use this
function here and presumably some of
these arguments when you add them would
be given optional parameters and so
nobody's code would break now if we
think about a library like matplotlib
remember some of these libraries in
addition to having this convenience
there also have the property of being so
fundamental to so many people's work
that they can change only very slowly
and so the way that matplotlib looks
today may be fundamentally how map out
looks in three or four years and if you
talk to the MATLAB core developers one
thing that they will tell you is their
timeline for how long this project will
exist maybe 15 20 years and so they have
a lot of serious considerations put into
how do we design this library so we
don't arbitrarily break code and so that
we don't arbitrarily have to chase after
changes made at this convenience layer
or changes made at this core layer and
how they affect each other now one thing
that you can think that's problematic
from a documentation perspective is so
let's say you know there just may be we
just say they're kind of lazy so they
didn't do this
so the problem is if we had documented
these explicitly and then we had added a
document here or we had removed an
argument here documentation is wrong so
we still have a dependency and we still
have a dispense D at the code layer it's
not a dependency in terms of what the
arguments take or what they don't but
there's a dependency in terms of every
time this changes you have to change
this documentation and which do you
think is worse like a code problem like
if you if you hard-coded the arguments
here and here and you got it wrong you
didn't update something then some user
is gonna use it it's gonna break they're
gonna go to github and say I hate you
you're stupid you're ugly this broke why
can't you do this right you open-source
people are useless people don't get hub
aren't very nice but they'll complain
and they'll complain very loudly and
very quickly and your test coverage
might also help you but if you create
the
dependence in the documentation how long
could bad documentation survive where
the documentation of what the arguments
are and what the art what the library
actually takes do not match up how long
could this sit unnoticed
with users constantly saying well hold
on I tried this argument because not
everyone's gonna use every single one of
these arguments so somebody in the
middle of nowhere let's say it's 3:00
a.m. because they went out drinking with
Ian Oswald and Vincent last night and
then they had to put a talk together and
it's 3:00 a.m. and they're struggling to
put their talk together and they try to
call a function and oh the documentation
says this but it's actually wrong it's a
very likely possibility so we have a
problem here where there's fundamentally
through these mechanisms of having
convenience layer and a core layer and
inability to reconcile them and to keep
them up to date in a way that doesn't
add a lot of human effort and also
doesn't break a lot of user code now one
of the problems that we face is that you
could say in this particular pattern
here there are patterns where we can
avoid this I'll show you an example the
common decorator pattern looks something
like this and I'm sure many of you have
written decorators before so it looks
something like this so and then maybe
this is a decorator on top of some core
function and you decorate it and this
does who cares right and we know that
there's one thing that we are encouraged
to do every time you write a decorator
to avoid this problem of if we run this
code and we look at the help text of
coure we'll see that it's the help text
of inner right it has the args in the
quarks and we're told there's one thing
we should do whenever we do a decorator
in order to solve this what's that one
thing we should do Phung tools dot wraps
so from funk tools import wraps and then
we should just do wraps F and with that
simple little thing the help text for
this decorator function looks normal and
so we don't have this problem anymore
the thing is does anyone know how fun
tools not wraps actually works it's a
very very simple mechanism that is not
in any way extensible what happens is
it just sets an attribute called rapper
and in PI doc when it generates the help
text it just follows the chains of the
rapper's to figure out what's the inner
most rapped function and so this funk
tools that rap really only works in the
case where you're doing like a decorator
pattern I think it's fun tools that rap
sets may be wrapped it only works when
you're in this yeah see it's there and
actually just wanna print this out so
I'll show you the wrapped function so it
only works in this very limited
circumstance so as a general mechanism
to avoid this problem funk tools dot
raps or similar approaches really don't
work because typically with these
convenience functions the pattern that
you see is you see multiple core
functions like if you think about
something like PI plot hist to generate
a histogram right it's calling a bunch
of internal math all the poor functions
and your hissing probably looks like
probably it takes like one of these
arguments and another one of these
arguments then star args and star kwargs
and that it probably does like or one
with some stuff and then core to what
some stuff and so this wraps technique
won't work and you can think well one
thing you could do is you could maybe
create some like documentation helper
that says you know forwards argument to
core 1 and core 2 and you do some
mechanism like that but this is gonna be
really invasive one of the goals of some
of the techniques that I show in my
talks is to identify what can we do in a
very minimal fashion and let's say 3
hours before you have to give a talk the
next day that could potentially be
useful with a little bit of extension
but do not require you to substantially
rewrite code how do you do these kind of
things surgically one thing that's very
popular in the Python community these
days and I can say that I'm on the I'm
on the fence with regards to it is
static analysis there is no such thing
as useful static analysis in Python even
for real libraries like matplotlib it
breaks very very very quickly let me
tell you what I mean by static analysis
many of you are familiar with pet 484
anyone know what pet 44 is type into and
you will think that well you know if we
can do things like type hinting you know
if you think about type hinting it's
kind of this idea that you you set the
type hints and you can you can
tract statically this arguments could
pass at this and if this was passed in
as an int we can check this as an int
over here but the thing is one very
important qualification that a lot of
people overlook when they get really
deep into type hinting is that it's not
a static validation or verification
technique type in ting is only a linting
technique there is no way for us to
dynamically or start to statically
assert that the types actually match up
in Python like we can do in C++ or Java
and so one thing that I encourage many
of you to do is to change my mind about
static type int or started change my
mind about type hints and the way you
can change my mind about type int is as
follows take a library of code that you
have worked on that somebody else mostly
developed that you're kind of confused
about how it works try to refactor it
and try to use type hints in order to
guide your refactoring presumably if
that's a helpful technique then by
adding hint annotations everywhere that
would give you enough understanding
about how the code works so you could
then refactor it but I don't think that
you'll you'll be very successful I think
that the snippet the typical technique
of dynamic analysis via unit tests is
what you'll have to do let me show you
an example of why this kind of stuff
simply doesn't work and why we couldn't
just go through the source code for
matplotlib and say well if it calls
Corps let's just grep for Corps like why
can't we just grep for every function
then grep for every function call within
those function calls and then we have
one flat file that says this function
calls this this and this this function
has this is this argument and then form
a tree from that well the problem is
even very simple and common patterns
will break this for example if they did
G equals Corps like this and they call G
so any kind of any kind of first-class
functions any kind of polymorphism
immediately breaks this one important
consideration when talking about things
like static verification or static
analysis of code bases is to understand
what does the typical code base look
like and what does a real code base not
some completely synthetic like I try to
do the most complicated thing in the
world code base look like but a real
code base like MATLAB or pandas in in my
review for this talk what I found is
even a fairly normal code base like
MATLAB has enough audit
deep inside of it that simple techniques
like like simples grep based static
analysis simply won't work however one
very nice benefit of code bases like
matplotlib and pandas is they tend to
have very large test suites and very
large example use case suites in many
cases those example use case suites are
not are not complete but they may be
complete enough to exercise enough of
the functionality so if I told you
instead of a attempting a static
analysis technique instead of attempting
to read through the source code and try
and figure out what passes to what and
what the call graph is what if we took
the example test code that matplotlib
has there's a million of those you see
them online if you look at the
matplotlib dot source code you can see
there's this folder here and we can even
say find name startup UI and see how
many there are so it's five hundred and
twenty six examples these aren't even
the test cases these are just the
examples and if we wanted to we could
even see how many lines there's thirty
four thousand lines of example code it
may not be complete at exercising all of
the functionality of matplotlib but it
probably represents a good amount of
what actually happens in a real map part
of code base with regards to how
arguments are passed what calls what and
we could maybe even with some dynamic
analysis techniques try to identify what
the code coverage is of the example test
suite of all the possible modalities
inside the library itself now the
problem is dynamic analysis techniques
and Python there's a couple of ways we
can do this very easily and there's a
couple of really easy tricks that you
can do to solve this problem of I have a
code base I have no idea where to start
looking
and I need I need a foothold one of the
common techniques that you might use is
module import analysis now I don't know
if I have an example of it for you
because I have a better way to do it the
module import analysis but you may know
that in Python there exists this thing
called I don't know if I have a really
good example I don't if I can write a
really good example for you but there is
meta path in Python and you might not
know what sis not meta path is what it
is is to
list of objects that can intercept
imports and so when you actually import
a module in Python it actually uses this
object here this built in importer to
identify is this a built in module how
do I import it this frozen importer is a
frozen module how to import it or this
pathfinder is this a module that sits
somewhere on my file system in some
paths and load that what we could do is
we could take this pathfinder we could
either patch it or we could insert
another another import helper another
import hook in the middle here and just
say when you try to import something
just record what you're trying to import
and then build a graph from that now
during the question and answer session I
might be able to find one of these
graphs that I built for a real code base
I don't have one off offhand but I built
these for real code bases where you can
take a large code base and say when you
run this against the test suite because
this is not a static analysis technique
it's a dynamic analysis technique it
requires that you actually run some code
somewhere so you need to have a sample
code base either test code or example
code but when you run this against a
test code base this module imports this
module imports this module imports this
module imports this module and so on
what do you think that could be useful
you want to figure out how to get
started on this code base you want to
figure out how to learn it
maybe the module that everything else
imports is a good place to start and
when you look at a real code base you
often see that there's like a core the
meat right and then there's a bunch of
leaves just a bread surrounding that
meat and it's like does anyone have a
friend who I have a friend who whenever
you go out to eat with them and they get
a sandwich they'll take the bread off
and just eat the meat yeah so that's
what you want to do when you're
analyzing a code base you don't want to
look at all the oh this is how you do
the configuration this is how you do the
file management oh if the configuration
files not in the home directory then
look in this other directory you don't
care about that you want to find the
core algorithmic or model code and often
in a real codebase it's very difficult
to find but if you had an import graph
it might not be that hard because almost
certainly the core algorithmic or or
model code is going to be imported by
everybody and at the leaves there'll be
the different applications or the
different helpers or different utilities
and you can ignore those at this
you'll also be able to see certain
patterns like is there are there modules
that everybody goes through those might
be configuration modules those might be
some global state modules and you can
get an understanding of that now the way
you do that is actually fairly simple
you just write an import hook pure
Python you don't have to do anything too
fancy but there's certain limits to that
technique which is you can only look at
you can only look at what imports what
you can't look at what you use this once
so if a module imported something and
never used it you'll get a little bit of
noise there for a real code base maybe
not a lot of noise but for you know at
the edges you might get a little bit of
noise and the net value of that for a
very big code base may not be that high
because there are code bases that just
don't have that that part that artichoke
heart worth of value that are just
smeared all over the place let me show
you or let me discuss briefly another
technique you might use many of you may
be familiar in the SIS model with set
profile you can set profiling hooks in
Python so that every time a let me see
if I can do this
so I'll show you an example so every
time I call a function the profiling
hook tells you when you call into a
function when you were turned and what I
can do in my profile and hook I get a
frame and some other garbage prints
frame dots KO code that ko name is that
it anyone no nobody come on okay we'll
just figure out what yeah thank you
somebody's paying attention that's good
so here's a coke oh no it's the the
frame code code okay let's do this we
got to figure out we got to figure out
what it is
so Oh dot F code very obvious I should
have known that worst talk ever I should
have gone to see what's the talk
opposite is about neural networks at
least you're not in another neural
networks talk so at least at least we're
having a little bit of fun so let me
just show you what this looks like this
should be the F code oh this one
involved drugs as well in its creation
maybe not in its presentation so what
you can see is when I call F you can see
you called into F you call them to G you
left G you left f so you can actually
get a you can fairly easily get a call
stack here so let me print out one more
thing I'll print out the event it's the
event and then some other garbage and
you'll see that with literally two lines
of Python code the creation of the hook
and the setting of the hook for a call
stack you can see I called him to F I
called him the G I returned from G and I
returned from F so basically about five
lines of code you could add this to your
site packages to your path run your
example code and you could see this
calls this calls this calls this calls
this returns calls this calls this
returns calls this and you could use
network X and you could build a very
simple graph from this and so that would
be another simple dynamic analysis
technique that you could employ the
dynamic analysis technique would be what
calls what in my example sweet and so
just like you could identify the central
most modules you can identify the
central most functions and one thing
that's missing though is none of these
can solve our arcs or quarks problem
while you could look at the functions
and you could grab the signatures from
those functions and say well this one
take stars and star star quarks and this
one takes ABC and make some inference
you don't really know what looks at what
so I want to show you the technique that
I employed and it was based on something
I did a while back called our watches
and it's a fairly simple technique that
took only about you know that much code
it took me a while to get this code to
work and there's actually some
duplication all this stuff is just cut
and paste three times but what I did it
really it's not that hard what I did was
I edited basically four or five files in
C Python the most important one being C
eval dot C and let me show you how
Python works whenever a bytecode runs
like whenever you do a binary POW like a
binary ad like you add two things
together python pops the two things
you're gonna add together from the top
of the stack it makes a place where the
sum is and then it calls into some code
here every time you need to actually and
I'll show you that I thought yes so if
we have a function that looks like this
and we disassemble it you can see it
loads two things onto the top of the
stack that a binary adds and that pushes
that there if you look at the load fast
you can see what it does is it pushes
something onto the stack so basically
every time you need to perform an
operation on a Python variable like add
it or call it you use a function to call
it you have to push it onto the stack so
the next operation can pop it off the
top of the stack well it turns out this
push is a macro which means we could
override that macro with a fairly
complicated macro that looks like this
and there's three versions of them I'll
show you why and what you can do is you
can say okay can I set as a watch target
that if the object that I'm pushing to
the top of the stack is a specific ID
that I want to keep an eye on call a
callback function so just like in the
set profile I was having callback
functions on the entering and closing of
functions here I can have a
all back function every time your Python
code looks at a variable not necessarily
does something with it but even looks at
it the moment it touches the top of the
Python stack it gets called and the
reason there's three of these and that
that one's called
push in this one's called watch is I can
also in specific byte code watch
specific events so here what I can do is
every time you try to store a local
variable I just omit an event have a
little callback or you can do whatever
you want with that I can write some
simple instrumentation code I have my
passsion interpreter with about 50 lines
of patch much of which is cut and paste
and I have a very simple little thing
here that when you yeah it's not that
bad you have a little stub and when this
tub gets activated there's a couple of
there's a couple of complexities that
were added here because I'm doing this
on every single push of every single
Python variable when I ran this on one
example from the map pod lab test case
it generated four gigabytes of output
data for a hundred line file the example
I'm going to show you as a five line
file that'll generate about three
megabytes of output data but I have I
have a big data problem so thankfully
this is a PI data talk so maybe out
maybe they'll ask me to speak next year
but the idea is every time you see a
variable get touched or looked at you
can record everything about that what
function was that variable looked at
what was the line number that touched
that variable what was the module and
you can generate enormous amount of
information now I'll show you a simple
example like this here's a simple
example that kind of matches this kwargs
arcs problem you have a function f that
goes through F and then G down to H okay
it had three arguments on the outside
and then it gets passed on the stack and
these could be in different modules it
could be all over the place you might
not even know which G this is because
that might be dynamically determined but
if you run this code and you watch these
three variables you can see or ABC got
passed in here got passed in here and
got passed in there what I end up
generating is a fairly large JSON file
with all of the times the variable is
looked at and this concludes the entire
call stack the line number the ID
and what the objects type was and what
the repair of the object was I also
generate some other information like the
modules these are all the modules that
were imported in the process of running
this and the last thing I generated
these are all the signatures of all the
functions that were involved so I can do
some fairly sophisticated techniques now
I didn't have time to put together a
really nice analysis but I put together
a fairly simple analysis and the
analysis I put together says given a
particular variable that I want to look
at what functions did that variable get
introduced into and get used in so I'll
show you this in practice because I know
I'm running out of time so we'll run it
here I know it's in this directory and
you can see even it's a very simple
technique like this we can do that and
then this generates a dot file and let's
take a look and this is the actual call
stack for that ABC variable I'll show
you the example one more time so that's
what the example looks like this is the
call stack you can see this variable was
introduced in the main module and used
in the H module so what I could do to
solve this quartz problem is quite
literally I can run through the map hall
of example code the problem is it's
gonna take like an hour to to run each
example but I can run through it and I
can tell you exactly what arguments got
passing at the top where did they get
looked at and I can infer from that
quite easily that look this ABC was
passed all the way through the stack I
know everywhere was passed and this is
where it terminated it didn't get passed
any further than that in fact if I
change the code so that it gets used in
G but not passed down then I'll get in a
different graph that shows me where it
was introduced and where it was used
this ends up generating a lot of data
that needs some fairly sophisticated
data analysis techniques because while
there is a little bit of noise there's a
lot of inference that you need to do a
lot of heuristic and for instant to do
to figure out how the code base worked
based off of this but the idea here is
something quite simple through hacking
an interpreter with some fairly minimal
fairly lightweight hacks honestly the
the hex that I did took about 30 45
minutes to do the hardest part of it was
you know you have to be somewhat
familiar with some pointer mechanics in
the Python code base but that's easy
enough to just kind of read up about but
with some fairly simple hacks I create
hacked interpreter which then gave me
significant instrumentation information
that I could then run into a code base
albeit when I run against the code base
I get about a sixty to a hundred times
slowdown but fundamentally because this
is an analysis technique that might be
used to supplement documentation it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter that
none of you want to install my hacked
Python it doesn't matter that it's slow
because if you think about the use case
what would the use case be once a month
before I do a release I run against my
hacked interpreter I don't even have to
keep the hacked interpreter up to date
because how long do you think matplotlib
is gonna support Python three seven
right ones ones map Holub gonna drop
support for Python three seven not for
another ten or fifteen years so I don't
have to keep this code up-to-date I just
have to make it run once I can put any
dirty hacks I need in there to satisfy
weirdness in the matplotlib code base
run it against the code base and start
generating graphs generating output
documentation that could then be used to
supplement to in an automatic fashion
supplement existing documentation here
you can see an example of how this you
can imagine could then be used to infer
what the args and kwargs actually are
what's actually used and you could
generate a very interesting kind of
coverage testing from this because you
can see what arguments or what
modalities exist in the code base that
aren't covered by your example codes you
can also do some other interesting
things here as well anybody here has
user input feeding into their system the
reason that you put what you put
watchpoints on the additional byte codes
is you can do taint analysis you can
take user input taint those objects
every time they're used in an expression
that gets stored to another object you
have the ability to look at when it's
when the computation for the result
value is and when the store happens and
you can tie those together so you can
take a string if somebody uppercase is
that string you can propagate the taint
from the original data to the new
expression and you can propagate the
taint throughout the system so you can
say this resulting value that I use in
this critical part of my system was tied
to some user input at the edges of my
system and maybe we need to make sure
that it's sanitized correctly there's a
lot of things you can do with very
little code that's fairly hacky and so I
hope that was an interesting example of
how these hacky and
protects actually can in some in some
context produce useful analysis of real
code bases without your having to do a
lot of software engineering or upstream
things just throw some hacks together in
your interpreter and see what can see
what you can do thank you
[Applause]
questions for James I hope that was I
hope that was interesting thanks for the
talk how much of this if anything can be
done with debuggers and can they
possibly be extended to cover some of
this so that we don't have to have hacky
so the reason the the first way I tried
to sell people on our watch was that you
could if you look at the name or watch
the reason it was created was to mimic
our watches in a debugger like gdb and a
debugger like gdb you can actually tell
gdb this memory location every time
somebody reads from that memory location
break so that you can see in a large
system like who's looking at this
information like a global variable and
you can track who's depending on that
global variable you can't do that in
Python at anything but the interpreter
level because the only way to hook into
that reading is by hooking into what
gets pushed or popped or what gets
involved in a byte code there is one
thing that's missing here which is once
python code goes into c code everything
becomes opaque because you can't look
through the interpreter stack can't look
through into c code it's very opaque
what I thought our watch would be
interesting is is as a debugger a very
slow debugger but a debugger where you
could do things like say in my ETL
pipeline track this piece of data all
the way through the pipeline and see
where it goes but nobody seemed to care
that much people seem to care more about
args and kwargs documentation really
putting a crimp in their style but yeah
I mean this this is essentially a
debugging technique repurposed for code
analysis a lot of questions
um I was wondering cuz have you ever
tried creating a graph like this in a
large code base and combining like all
the different graphs to make one huge
graph for the entire I did about 15
minutes ago and it takes and if the
problem is it's possible it just takes
it just it's gonna take more computing
resources than I was able to put
together for this presentation so
actually in this example you can look at
all of the variables and the analysis
I'll show you it's a little bit
difficult to read the graph without a
little bit more work and the
presentation of it let me show you what
I mean here do this and this rerun this
and I'll show you this is the graph if
you look at every variable and the path
of every variable there's a good amount
of noise here
because there's a lot of variables you
simply don't care about like this F and
this G is the name of the functions F
and G themselves so you'd want to elide
them now the point of this technique
being hacky is that every code base will
have certain things that you know for
certain you don't care about looking at
and instead of generalizing that
technique which would be an enormous
amount of effort you just hack away
don't look at a function if it's called
F don't look at something if it goes
into this module one problem that
happens with the matplotlib code base is
because of the way if I remember
correctly because of the way that I was
running it some of the Python code for
the site package import Lib was
generating at least a gigabyte of out
potato and so all I did when I was when
I was trying to put that together was if
you're looking at a module call a
function call in the import Lib module
just ignore it because I could I
couldn't I could in a reactive fashion
look at my data look at my code base and
say ignore this this and this and only
pay attention to that now I don't know
what this graph really tells you that's
it's so large but it does tell you
something interesting you can see the
call structure and you can see you can
actually kind of see things getting
passed through from F down to H and you
can see you can see that it gets passed
all the way down and you'd see that G
doesn't really do anything because the
only variables G looks at are the the
this is the arcs tuple the quarks tuple
and the function name and that the
actual function arguments the ABC the
ABC the d EF in the
so I said are only looked at in the F in
the G so you can begin to see in this
larger example how the arguments flow
through the system and you and this is
just one analysis you could do I mean
presumably if you wanted to play with
this and if any of you are interested
playing with this what we could do is we
could take my code run it against a code
base overnight generate gigantic pandas
data frames or CSV files or JSON data
frames like probably about a gigabyte
each and then give it to people and say
okay what can you infer from this you
could probably even have four
opportunities for optimization without
too much difficulty you could see
repeated calls with the same input
arguments so you could see places where
memoization isn't occurring things like
that let's thank James again then
[Applause]